please welcome to the stage the creator
of the game awards Jeff Keeley
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everybody Welcome to summer game
Fest
[Applause]
we are in person and today we've got a
look at what's next in video games for
you we are live here in Los Angeles at
YouTube theater and it feels so good to
be in person with a live fan audience
for the first time ever welcome
everybody
when I started summer game Fest back in
2020 from a spare bedroom I never
imagined it would grow into this today
the video game industry has come
together to show you what's next this is
a cross industry showcase meaning no
matter where you play games I hope
you'll discover a new game to put on
your wish list the landscape of video
game events has certainly changed over
the past few years but one thing hasn't
there are a lot of great games in
development and our singular goal today
is to get you excited about the future
in just a few minutes we'll see the
first extended gameplay of Mortal Kombat
one
[Applause]
it delivers don't worry Alan Wake two
the reveal of fortnite's next season
and yes
we do have a very special Grand Finale
that you're not gonna want to miss all
I'll say right now
but let's get right to the games and
game play the first reveal is something
you're not expecting which makes it that
much more exciting here we go
the prince has been kidnapped
but they didn't land
all hope rests with us the Immortals to
rescue him and save the Empire
we weren't prepared for what was coming
next up so I can't say no
then again they weren't prepared for me
shows
[Music]
gotta do all of the enemies
man
these times of Darkness hope is the only
thing that keeps us fighting
I will fulfill my destiny and save the
kingdom
foreign
[Applause]
is coming in January 2024 a brand new
action adventure platformer in the
iconic series with deep combat some huge
boss fights and of course incredible
platforming puzzles and animation
bringing a modern take on the legendary
franchise you'll be able to see more at
Ubisoft forward streaming on Monday as
part of Summer game Fest all right let's
move along to another iconic video game
franchise that just celebrated 30 years
that's right it's time for Mortal Kombat
one
[Applause]
you waiting on this one
it has been four years since MK 11 and
ever since Ed Boone the team at
netherrealm have been hard at work on
the most ambitious MK yet that reboots
the series into a New Era timeline and
it's coming this September everyone has
been asking what does it look like who's
on the roster how do the new Cameo
Fighters work well now it is time for
combat no spoilers but this video is
literally insane here is an extended
First Look At The Story gameplay and yes
of course the fatalities
[Applause]
no combat one let's do it
[Music]
I have had enough of you then go before
I put you down
[Music]
today
you have proven worthy of joining us oh
there are other Champions I must gather
what do you want sento it's my family
blade cento's mine and I won't give it
up without a fight
[Music]
foreign
okay let's go back to one here
who are you again Lord Liu Kang
protector of Earth rail
god of fire
you have skills Raiden but you're
inexperienced whatever experience I lack
I make up for in heart
thank you
[Music]
if your disease becomes known you will
be banished I only want what's best for
you or do you secretly covet my throne
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
I mean that was pretty good right guys
now I'm sure you have many questions
about what we just saw and to tell you
more I am so honored to welcome to
summer game Fest one of our industry's
greatest creators a man who has been
loyal to the same franchise and fan base
for more than three decades please join
me in welcoming to summer game Fest the
creator of Mortal Kombat Ed
[Applause]
[Music]
congratulations
they love you all right well Ed uh first
of all thank you for that incredible uh
World premiere we got to see all the
gameplay of MK1 and everyone just wants
to know more about this because first of
all this isn't a it's MK1 right we went
from 11 to one so tell us about this is
it a new timeline yeah yeah um I don't
know how many people have seen the the
ending of Mortal Kombat 11 Liu Kang
basically was kind of graduated into
like you know a fire god right and he's
he created a brand new universe and this
universe this is why we're calling it
Mortal Kombat one is because this is the
beginning of a new timeline a number of
these characters you've seen before but
they're told in a completely different
story and so Sub-Zero and Scorpion are
brothers now and there's there's all
these things that were rivalries before
are now allies and so mixing the whole
thing up so we're just kind of rebooting
and that's what the one is for well it
looks incredible everything we saw there
was you know in game gameplay the
cinematics look incredible I know the
team has been working for four years on
this but the thing we gotta talk about
are these cameos because we saw some
pretty amazing stuff there now tell us
how does that work you obviously you
have your sort of your main you know
character that you'll pick and then I
know you also have a separate kind of
Cameo menu so you pick sort of a pair
when you start the game yeah normally in
in a fighting game you'll you'll see a a
roster basically you know where you
select your character after you do that
there's a second roster of characters
which are a whole new uh completely
different Fighters that are the Cameo
Fighters and these Fighters actually
they will join the fight but they let
the blank squares there yes so it's kind
of like imagine yourself with sub-zero
but you have some of Jack's moves and
you can call him out you can do it
multiple times as you saw in the
gameplay you know so you can piece you
can basically combine these two
characters all the characters can be
combined with all the Cameo Fighters and
that's where you see that's where the
players kind of imagination comes in and
they can actually customize it for what
they like seeing you know the best team
ups well so how does that work so you're
in game play you have your main you have
your cameo how do you if you summon them
is it time base like how often do they
come into it's not a tag team thing
right yeah yeah exactly and and you're
you're basically summoning them it's
just one button pushes basically
summoning but they have a variety so you
can go you know push that button with
towards and it'll do a different move
push it with down it'll do a different
move and so the combination oh I see so
you can bring them in a combo exactly
exactly and and so and you see there's
like a meter up on top which is
basically that that'll limit it so you
can't obviously fire them yeah
indefinitely but um you call you can
call them pretty much whatever you want
and they have you know like in the
middle of a combo they'll have a lot of
um you know basically a whole arsenal of
their mood so Sony eats all come out
there sometimes you'll see them appear
twice in there
today so time base they come out and
then obviously as you go through you
revealed some of them there but is it a
different set of characters that'll be
in the cameos are there some repeats
from the main roster how will that work
yeah yeah some of the characters are
going to be available as cameos as well
as the main roster fighter so you can
play Sub-Zero with sub-zero right you
can play
you can same thing with scorpion but a
lot of our our Cameo Fighters are kind
of like nods back to our first game so
you'll notice Sonia and Kano and Jax are
in their kind of older costumes and so
there's there's a lot of that novelty we
have a lot of like really surprised ones
I think you guys saw Goro yes
so there's a lot of like kind of really
digging into the old Mortal Kombat games
as far as getting you know um we really
love the novelty of it we really want
the Cameo characters to feel uh you know
kind of Nod to the old games
well speaking of uh 90 old games let's
talk you confirmed I think or at least
knowing that Jean-Claude Van Damme is
actually going to be in this game as
Johnny Cage right is that true yeah
that was people don't know know the
story I mean Bloodsport was such an
inspiration for Mortal Kombat so he
finally is now yeah it's a huge first uh
full circle moment you know the the
first Mortal Kombat game we originally
wanted to be Van Damme the video game
and that and that never really worked
out so I I can't tell you how many times
over the last 30 years we've tried to
get him uh you know we were this close
like four or five times and uh so
finally we got him and he's doing the
voices too wow so you're going to hear
John Claude his voice doing Johnny Cage
lines and stuff like that we're really
excited about it wow well I know the
team has been working so hard in Chicago
to build this through covid and it's
coming out in September so we don't have
to wait long right that's right with
this this has been a very difficult uh
secret to keep over the last over the
last four years and so uh but we're
we could not be more excited in terms of
uh getting players hands on it um and
you know throughout the summer we're
going to be showing a lot more content a
lot more characters a lot more Cameo
characters you know so there's a lot of
reveals that are coming up amazing well
Ed thank you so much for giving us the
first look at MK1 as you said this
weekend people will be playing at
Preston media so we'll be seeing lots
more coverage lots more characters to
reveal on the main roster in cameos uh
Ed Boone thank you so much first look at
Mortal Kombat awesome
amazing so excited about that one all
right next up it's been a fun couple
weeks for Action RPG fans with the
release of Diablo 4 which is truly
fantastic another big and anticipated
arpg is Path of Exile 2 from grinding
gear games who have Faithfully been
updating and patching the original Poe
since its release in 2013. we haven't
seen anything on the sequel in over two
years but that changes right now here is
your first look at a raw gameplay
capture from Path of Exile 2 a sequel
that pushes the engine and gameplay to a
new level
[Applause]
where are the guards
hey you what's going on
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
looks amazing and there's more coming in
July last week marked the release of
Street Fighter VI a game we featured
last year at summer game Fest well the
team at Capcom has an important update
to share with you right now
[Music]
I am the advanced artificial
intelligence Leviathan
[Music]
TOA Island
I'm guessing Ryu from Street Fighter
facing off against a dinosaur probably
wasn't on your bingo card for today's
show
that Street Fighter cross exoprimal
collab will launch in the fall with the
game coming out on July 14th
but guess what guys that may actually
not be the craziest collaboration on the
show today check this out
there's nothing more powerful than
imagination
[Music]
shape the fabric of real
swarming everything you may think you
know
[Music]
thank you
that's right Nicholas Cage is coming to
dead by daylight in July I mean I don't
know how these things happen but
I figured the easiest way to find out is
probably to go right to the source
this man's bold creative choices have
earned him an Academy Award and a few
memes on the internet across more than
four Decades of incredible films please
join me in welcoming to summer game fast
Nicholas Cage
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
thank you everybody thank you happy to
meet you Nick I gotta say welcome to the
Video Game World oh wow yeah thank you
I'm so happy to be invited to your very
very cool Club everybody
finally I mean I gotta say this is such
a crazy unexpected collaboration I gotta
understand how did this come out I mean
some people be like oh maybe he'll show
up in Fortnight maybe he'll be in hideo
Kojima game but dead by daylight I mean
how does this happen well it's it's a
museum of horror right yes and when I
make movies one of my favorite genres is
horror and in this and and in that genre
there's a character a murderous ghost
named sadiko who I think is amazing and
she made an appearance in this game so
that was good enough for me okay yeah I
mean that's what's fun is you're playing
one of the survivors in this game and
it's cool that you know it really is
this Museum of horror Michael Myers you
said all these different characters all
coming together
um and you do you you play yourself or
who do you play so I play this uh
heightened
exaggerated version of a film actor
named Nick Cage
he's uh he's going to a location
thinking he's making a movie and instead
he wakes up in the fog and in the fog
he's surrounded by crows and serial
killers and it's rather amusing and
there's something about it that I think
as a Survivor is like a bonding
experience it's a bit like hide and go
seek you have your three other teammates
who are survivors with you and it's
teamwork you're working together to pull
through and I like that and so that was
a large reason for wanting to do it as
well that that feeling of bonding with
your friends and you're fully Infamous I
know we heard your voice in there so you
recorded lines for it everything see I
want you to know when you're playing the
Nick Cage Survivor I even have when
you're choosing your skins I even say
always remember to dress to match your
talent I want you to know that you're
with me that we're one that were fused
and so it was important to me that
everything I do everything I say from
the scream to the grunt down to the most
minimal exasperated expression of a sigh
whatever it is it's my voice so that we
are fused all right
bowling left cage I love it I I mean
this is so fun this game as you said is
such an awesome kind of you know
collaboration with so many different
characters for you I mean how did you
find out about dead by daylight do you
know much about the video somebody very
important in my family is a dead by
daylight Enthusiast and and that really
put the uh hook in huh pun intended uh
uh see dead by daylight to me was an
opportunity to Branch out to I've never
been invited into this space before I'm
always looking for new adventures so
this to me was like wow I can I make it
I can make a whole new audience meet a
whole new audience and Branch out and go
on this dead by daylight Adventure I
didn't say it took me nothing but a
split second to say yes and speaking
about split seconds what excuse me what
I noticed excuse me sinuses uh allergies
what I noticed was that every move you
make when you're doing this when you're
in the gaming space it's it's time down
to the Split Second it's a very very
immersive experience when you're acting
out in this space because every move
every grunt every saw you make has to be
timed perfectly with the gamers moves so
that was something that I learned from
this and I'm always looking to learn
something well we love having you in the
video game where we want to see Nick
Cage more games thanks guys
[Applause]
lock it in
now for all of you who want to play Nick
Cage in dead by daylight the chapter
officially comes out on July 25th on PC
and console but PC players can try it
earlier by downloading the player test
build on July 5th and here's an
exclusive first look at Nicholas Cage in
dead by daylight
[Music]
thank you
damn right I made it
[Applause]
anything goes here at Summer game Fest
all right thank you very much Nick
foreign
[Music]
zero one operation control clears you
for engagement
[Music]
foreign
let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
what's up
we have no choice
the route will destroy
everything
for all time
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
all right we have much more summer game
Fest to come including a first look at
the gameplay of Alan Wake 2 the world
premiere of the new season of fortnite
Call of Duty season four and maybe a few
more surprises for you as we go through
today's reveals use the hashtag gaming
on tick tock on Tick Tock to react to
the news and we want to welcome everyone
co-streaming the show live on Tick Tock
twitch YouTube and other platforms for
those of you on Twitch we also have a
special Warframe twitch drop a free
steinx Warframe for watching more than
30 minutes of the show now speaking of
surprises another legendary gaming hero
is set to return later this year in a
brand new game built from the ground up
in a style that I think is going to get
this fan base and long time fans of
video games very excited here's another
summer game Fest Global game
announcement new Thrills with a classic
feel
[Music]
good
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
how about that a new standard for 2D
Classic Sonic that's bound to appeal to
new and Legacy fans alike
this past April honkai star rail
launched and as you're about to see the
game is bringing an exciting new
character to space fantasy RPGs however
we don't just have a new Peak for
current players but also for those
awaiting the game's release on
Playstation take a look
I wish this universe had a few more
things to do don't you get bored running
across the map every day
please them duties mission one
accomplished where's our next stop I
can't leave
another busy day ahead of us
[Music]
[Applause]
tournament starting great let me get
warmed up
strike first
need a hand my pleasure
let's see some Sparks Fly
[Music]
huh never mind I miscalculated
time for a buzz
[Music]
[Applause]
later this year on Playstation all right
inspired by the story of Pinocchio Liza
p is a soulsborne like game from the
team at neowiz which is coming to Game
Pass PlayStation and PC this year well
if you're wondering exactly when we have
news to share with you on its release
with this brand new trailer
[Applause]
[Music]
need your help
[Applause]
I'm gone
[Music]
foreign
listen pal nice landing but uh let's not
make it a habit
[Music]
[Applause]
that's right a demo for lies of p is now
available across Playstation Xbox and PC
check it out and prepare for the release
on September 19th now it's time for the
reveal of a visually stunning new game
based on a classic manga with a story
and World created by one of the most
celebrated anime artists of all time
this is one of those games that I feel
lucky we get to reveal for the first
time here at Summer game Fest and I
think you'll be pretty hyped once you
see the gameplay all built in Unreal
Engine 5. here we go
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
get ready to become an unlikely hero and
Adventure where you don't need to be
human to save Humanity uh that's coming
from Bandai Namco and we're excited to
see more of it soon independent games
are such an important part of the
industry and one thing that's very
important to us at summer game Fest is
supporting those creators as well after
the live show stay tuned for Day of the
devs from I'm 8bit and double fine with
some incredible indie game reveals now
one of the biggest independent
Publishers is Anna Perna interactive and
later this month as part of Summer game
Fest they'll be revealing a number of
ambitious new projects let's see how
many you can figure out in this little
tease
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
we'll find out later this month all
right next we're stepping into the world
of throne and Liberty a free-to-play PC
on Console MMORPG from ncsoft and Amazon
games with an always-changing
environment massive scale pvpve and the
ability to transform into creatures to
battle across land sea and air here's a
look at throne and Liberty
[Music]
the world
foreign
destroying anything in their path
find them
their power
[Music]
and put down this threat once and for
all
[Music]
thank you
foreign
looks great I also want to say hello to
everybody watching on Steam right now
I'm sorry we don't have any free steam
decks for you right now but on June 19th
steam nextfest does return giving fans a
chance to try out hundreds of new
in-development games one of them is the
free to play medieval fantasy sword
fighting game warhaven from Nexon which
lets you transform into Supernatural
Immortals here's a new look
hey
[Music]
thank you
pilgrims summer is coming and we did a
lot of cool stuff will make his way to
Dying Light to stay human get ready for
darker more dangerous nights and roaming
volatiles complete with improved parkour
rolling out with the next update in June
then right after that we'll kick off an
even season like you have never seen
before trust me for one of them you will
want to get your butt Barbed wired very
soon you will get the deadliest Summers
to date
they don't care
YouTube
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to summer game Fest isn't
that great by the way crash team Rumble
is going to feature playable Ripper Roux
and engine
neocortex's right hand guy in Season one
now it's time to change the topic and
descend into madness joining me is a guy
who was last on stage at the game awards
2021 to announce Alan Wake 2.
he's come all the way from Finland
please welcome from remedy Sam Lake
[Applause]
see you looking Dapper as always thank
you thank you well we are so excited
because when you announced uh Alan Wake
at the game where I'll link two at the
game awards you said 2023 we are in 2023
it's coming this October and we are so
excited about the Sam I know it's been a
long time coming for fans and for you 13
years since the first Alan Wake so tell
us a bit about what can we expect in the
sequel it's been quite a journey yes
Alan Wake 2 is remedy's first survival
horror game we have two playable
characters it's a 50 50 split between
them they are on their own separate
terrifying Journeys through two
different worlds and yet it's all
connected and the player gets to switch
between them at given points in the in
the story as they choose
yeah we saw obviously uh the PlayStation
event you revealed uh Saga the the
second character uh tell us a bit about
her she's in bright Falls and she's sort
of living a narrative that Alan has
written is that right well uh that's a
good question to ask going into this so
yes we we have Alan Wake our Title
Character of course trying to escape
from The Nightmare dimension of the dark
place yeah and then we have Saga our new
hero FBI agent uh coming to the Pacific
Northwest small town of Pride falls
together with her partner yes Alex Casey
okay
and they're somehow linked in some way
right uh they are coming to investigate
yes a series of ritualistic murders okay
and and very quickly the investigation
turns into a nightmare when they
discover pages of a Horror Story uh
maybe written by a certain missing
writer uh initials AAW and and this
Horror Story starts to come true
around them interesting so obviously
it's you know Allen is still going to be
playable in the game you're going to
experience his journey but at Saga this
is her new character and there is that
sort of Link tell us a bit about you
said split 50 50 do they have separate
missions how because I think you can you
can play them in sort of different
sequences or orders if you want right
yeah we we go into the experience
playing as as Saga okay and and
it's a sequel but it's also a standalone
experience we are not expecting
everybody to do homework if they have
not played the original game uh this can
be enjoyed uh as is Saga doesn't know
anything about the lore about the
supernatural uh in this world she will
be going in very quickly if she has to
learn to survive and with that all the
players uh will be on on that Journey
with with her and and uh then we open up
the experience so that you can hope to
play Alan Wake in the dark place as he's
trying to find his way out and you can
keep on playing as Saga in the Pacific
Northwest as the investigation goes on
and you are free to switch between them
there are a lot of connection points yes
uh in many surprising ways but there is
no right way to play through this you
can choose you can and go on as as Alan
all the way close to the end or a saga
or you can keep hopping between these
two uh sorry well you're always so good
at kind of telling challenging
interesting narratives in unique ways I
mean remedy's always been known for that
new especially so we can't wait to see
how these stories intertwine I'm sure
throughout the experience today though I
know you brought with you some some
gameplay of saga's Adventure we're just
gonna see a raw segment of the game
right yeah raw gameplay for the first
time ever this is early on from The
Experience they're hyped Sam they're
ready for it
what are we going to see uh
Supernatural policies of Darkness have
uh brought the murder victim uh in this
case Back to Life as a monster and and
uh Saga is outside Pride Falls at
cauldron Lake trying to find him and
stop him
okay with that let's take a look at Raw
unedited gameplay from Alan Wake too
thanks Sam thank you
[Applause]
sounds like somebody's home
still coffee
[Applause]
[Music]
the text on the heart is clearer now
legible
I knew it would be here like I saw it in
a dream
[Music]
I'm glad you're on this case with me
Anderson
killer left a message
it's for us
we were all trapped in a horror story
The Horror Story wanted us dead
there's something unforgetting
something important
it's not right
[Applause]
a long time coming but Alan Wake 2 looks
incredible thank you to Sam and remedy
for that first look at gameplay now
let's get a first look at the co-op
campaign of Warhammer Space Marine 2
from saber and focus
[Music]
and it engaged us on two planets avadox
and kadaku
straight with your title
Titan I have my reservations about your
reinstatement there could be questions
would that be a problem no Captain
[Music]
my pledge
is
inbound
official rate this abomination
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
beautiful indie game yes to your grace
snowfall now it is time for another
Global game announcement and this one
comes from the minds of saber
interactive Focus entertainment and yes
horror Master John Carpenter It's a
Brand New World a brand new story and
looks like a heck of a lot of fun check
this out
[Music]
nobody half-asses at this time
on my mark
five
four three
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
collaboration Sean Carpenter and Savor a
toxic Commando that looks uh tons of fun
you guys think any of those zombies made
it
well this August brings the long-awaited
full 1.0 release of Baldur's Gate three
and today a new member is joining the
cast we're about to see the reveal of
Lord Ember gortash the commander of a
mechanical Army of Steel Watchers he's a
second antagonist and is voiced by
[Music]
the gortash
swear us thou by boldren's blade to
defend the citizens of Baldur's Gate
from enemies within and without
you are soon to witness the people of
Baldur's Gate granting me complete power
over
there a new age is upon us
gods have mercy on those who would stand
in our way a Mad Dog understands the
yank of the leash on the hand of its
master
cannot be an equal
you
can be my equal there's an old wisdom
was brittle Alliance a liar can never be
mended it can only break I want to lead
this city to Glory not Scorch at Earth
friends allies to my side
let us Usher in a new dawn this city is
mine
I'm not ready to call you enemy what do
you say
shall we be allies
who said he was under control
it isn't you I answer to
gortash
[Music]
baller's Gate 3 is on tracks Fenn tells
me still for the end of August and we
can't wait to check that out all right
this fall Marvel games and Insomniac are
set to bring Spider-Man 2 exclusively to
PlayStation 5. sounds like you guys are
a little hyped to the tell us more is
Brian into Heart game director at
Insomniac Brian thanks for coming by I
know you guys are deep in development
first of all looks like we have some uh
fancy art behind us is this the Box this
is the boxer you know
isn't it here it is I mean
has two on the box for a reason because
this game features two Spider-Mans so
we're really excited about it absolutely
uh Peter and Miles uh we're so excited
about this um you know experience that
you guys are doing with these sort of
two characters uh we saw some great
Gameplay at the PlayStation showcase but
I want to talk about the two
villains I think in the game there may
be more there are more there are more
out there two main ones but uh we have
some new art to show of uh we obviously
Craven we got the reveal at the
PlayStation event so tell us a bit about
uh him and how he says Craven's very
different from any character we've done
he's not you know he's not powered by
magic or you know Tech he's just
hunter in the world and he's coming to
New York for his greatest hunt and
what's better than all of the Marvel
characters that live in New York City so
Peter miles and others he's on the hunt
and others yes but uh Venom also
obviously uh you know symbiote is a part
of this whole story as we saw in the
gameplay oh there you go
good reaction to the art uh I'm glad
you're happy I don't know how much
you're gonna you're gonna tell us about
then is this uh can you tell is this is
an Osborne Venom okay tell us what's the
origin of Eddie Brock Venom or it is not
Eddie Brock okay it is not it is not
Eddie Brock okay
um our goal was to tell an original
story something you haven't seen in the
comics of the movies yet obviously wow
we love venom for a reason yeah all
those things you love about the
character are going to be there but how
the story plays out
who is Venom you have to play the game
and see how it goes really yeah wow okay
that's there's a bit of a tease now
obviously the the Symbiote is a big part
of the gameplay and and one of the
things like we were all struck with the
footage that you showed at the
PlayStation showcase was uh you know how
that is going to really impact the
gameplay when you're playing as you know
Peter so tell us a bit about that and
how you know the gameplay is going to be
dramatically different yeah I mean I
think you saw in just the the raw power
the strength and even the transformation
of of Peter's moves in that in that in
that gameplay reveal you know he's you
know we call him the acrobatic
improviser him and miles but you can
tell there's a lot more strength a lot
more raw power aggression which you saw
both in the moves and how Peter talks so
yeah it's not just what happens in Game
plates what happens how the story plays
out interesting so that affects him as
well yeah I mean you saw some of that
yeah there's much more of that Journey
when you play the game and I know that
the journey is also more expansive
you've got Queens Brooklyn so even more
of sort of yeah I mean the city has
pretty much doubled in size so it's
meant it's Manhattan Queens Brooklyn and
then being able to use the web Wings to
Traverse at speeds way faster than they
were before
um is really awesome
usually ambitious game you guys have
been building uh over the past few years
we saw at the um the PlayStation event
uh it said at the end fall
2023 and I think you know we're like
getting close to that are you guys
feeling confident that gonna make it
this fall
you know Jeff I know you like exclusives
yes
and I can promise you we are very
confident what we're going to tell you
right now oh yeah okay yeah let's take a
look
[Music]
nail it in October 20th Spider-Man 2
exclusively for PlayStation 5. got it
awesome well Brian thanks so much for
stopping by I know you got a lot of work
to do wrapping up the game but we'll
check it out in October thanks Brian
we got our Danes all right now let's
take a look at Power World a multiplayer
open world survival crafting game where
you can befriend and collect mysterious
creatures called pow who can also fight
in other words it's kind of like Pokemon
with guns and then
we're gonna look at the land of the
Morning Light a new expansion to Black
Desert online which recreates the
mythical folk tales from Korea's joseon
Dynasty and some huge bosses too
foreign
[Music]
we told it ourselves
with hammer and ax we mine and sculpt
across Middle Earth
gelding for riches
yet the greatest treasure remains out of
our reach Moria
[Music]
come my fellow dwarves
granny together
time
back our home
[Music]
all right
all right now we're going to look at an
exciting new mobile game from a
legendary franchise
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
pre-registration for Final Fantasy VII
ever crisis has just started and users
will have the chance to participate in
upcoming closed beta test now speaking
of Final Fantasy
today during summer game Fest doordash
has your back get eight you can get a
free burrito when you order from Taco
Bell using the code gamefest plus get
the chance to win a final fantasy 16
prize pack doordash stay in your game
yep we got you all right now here's a
look at the game we debuted last year at
TGA banishers ghosts of new Eden the
story of two ghost hunters in the
haunted Wilds of North America
[Music]
life to the living death to the Dead
we are banishers
we end suffering for those who live
we bring closure to those who don't care
[Music]
I want us back ridden
want to live
[Music]
as the man says we Face a choice so
it's an awful
[Music]
death to the dead
do we kill
okay
[Music]
to be part forever
come out come on
sweet bread
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
good morning Stanley it is 7 32 a.m I
hope you have a productive day
change username to just Stan
adjusting morning wake up good morning
just stand race to capsule 12 come in
you this then green across the board
looks like we're good
definitely a lake here Tim
[Music]
how long has it been now
three years
two months and 17 days
[Music]
all sort of operation are they running
down here
[Music]
these shouldn't be here
someone there
this doesn't make sense
is someone else down here
[Music]
are you there
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a beautiful new game under the
waves and today incidentally is World
ocean day fun fact all right next Call
of Duty well there's a new Call of Duty
coming this fall along with Warzone
Mobile today we're going to give you the
first ever look at season four of Modern
Warfare 2 war zone launching next week
here's your first look at bondle a new
War Zone location with points of
interest including medieval castle a
soccer stadium and an abandoned Zoo yep
it's all happening check it out here you
go
foreign
[Music]
got a problem
season four next week today is a big day
for video games but also a huge day for
Porsha the iconic German automaker
turned 75 years old today and to
celebrate their contributions in the
automotive and gaming space and we've
all raced a 911 in some point at a game
Xbox has teamed up with Porsha for a
limited edition run of 75 consoles
inspired by six famous Porsche race cars
and I'm thrilled to debut the first
design here today inspired by the
Porsche 963 that's racing this weekend
at the 100th running of the 24 Hours of
Le Mans let's take a look
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Applause]
Xbox series X these custom consoles are
not for sale but you can enter for a
chance to win one right now at Porsche
Xbox sweepstakes.com make sure to stay
tuned for the Porsche and Xbox social
channels for additional opportunities to
get your hands on these special consoles
all right next
Phoenix labs are building the next great
entry into the Cozy Farm Sim John we all
like a cozy game inspired by Classics
like Animal Crossing and stardew Valley
previously announced for Nintendo switch
there's now some exciting news for PC
players too let's take a look at Faith
Farm
dear friend life in azorious been
treating me well
[Music]
before I know it they turn into seasons
it's been a breath of fresh air
I think we found a way to get cozy and
settle in
[Music]
but there's something more I've been
itching to explore
Realms where magic comes to meet us
as long as we're prepared we can face
anything
so what do you say
there's so much yet to discover are you
ready
[Music]
[Applause]
we promise variety there it is Faith
Farm and Mortal Kombat in the same show
only at summer game Fest now please
welcome Ben brode Chief development
officer and flannel Enthusiast at second
dinner the developers behind the popular
collectible card game Marvel snap what's
up
man you guys have been on fire last time
I saw you was at the game awards when
you won uh best mobile game uh seems
like you've been very busy we're excited
about the spider-verse content you've
been doing Lots going on over there
right yeah it's been uh it's been
exciting we've been doing a bunch of new
features some of the wildest cards we've
ever made and uh um
game modes yeah yeah new game is that is
that a Segway Ben certainly yeah I'm
excited to announce Marvel snaps biggest
update ever uh we have a new game mode
coming next week it's it's Conquest mode
it's a great way to get a super
competitive experience uh in some
exciting new rewards but you don't have
to wait till next week if you haven't
tried model snap go down there right now
on your mobile device or early access on
Steam all right I love the enthusiasm
Ben that's what I got that's you you're
made for YouTube all right well we heard
you brought uh something fun uh with you
for us to watch right oh yeah so listen
I am incredible at card games so I often
win uh but some people and maybe you've
had the experience Jeff uh some people
lose yeah okay fair and I like to think
it's because they suck no offense Jeff
but sometimes sometimes it's because
they might just be a little bit unlucky
cue the tape
oh snap
okay I don't have an ideal hand of cards
here but that's fine I'll see what I
draw in future turns anyway let's reveal
the first location
each player destroys their deck okay I
guess I will work with I have I'll play
Medusa on location number two she gets
plus two power and let's see the even
this location Clover Dangerfield has a
25 chance of destroying your cow okay
well I mean 25 isn't that bad and it's
gone okay well I have some powerful
cards in my hand so I can just wait
let's see the next location the Big Barn
players cannot play four five or six
cost cows
also if you don't play a card this turn
you have zero friends
[Music]
still the cow we're gonna look at
Immortals of AVM from EA originals and
ascendant and the world premiere first
look at chapter four season three of
fortnite Wilds now if you're looking for
the smartest way to level up your gaming
this summer compare top credit cards
side by side with nerd wallet and start
maximizing your cash back rewards on
everything from Wi-Fi to headsets now
here's a look at King Arthur Legends
rise a new cross-platform
ue5 game from mobile and PC a fantasy
Squad RPG Adventure that is available to
pre-register today
to save your kind
[Applause]
With Honor
thank you
[Music]
wayfinders
do you remember the fall
the Gloom descended on skylight
rally to protect the beacon
terrible
profel and the world was broken
remember who you were
who you are and return to us
this world needs champions
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
good morning scavenger
set your surroundings to retrieve and
recycle anything that could be of value
to scavax
[Music]
Captain's Log stardate 43152.4
our Fleet is cautiously entering hostile
territory
and the crew is standing by contact
[Music]
s us
who hasn't dreamed of duplicating
oneself in order to multitask this new
hack and slash game with a tactical
twist allows you to do just that brought
to you from France here's the world
premiere reveal trailer of lisfunga the
time shift Warrior coming later this
year to PC
goddess of time
receive my life's less hunger let this
power flow through you and again
alongside your past
I'm here again
[Music]
foreign
I will become Legion and Crush these
demons
onwards I can feel that there are more
foreign
[Applause]
game all right next up is a brand new IP
from ascendant Studios a single player
first person magic shooter called
Immortals of avium it's fast and fluid
it's an FPS in a fantasy setting kind of
like Doom with magic it also has a great
cat cast led by Darren Barnett as the
main character Jack and he joins us now
hey Darren hey guys great to have you
with us thank you this is such a cool
game super high production value
spectacular gameplay uh tell us about
the guy you play You're the main
character Jack right yes I'm playing the
main character Jack as seen behind me
he's a battle mage that controls all
three forms of magic Triple Threat uh
he's Brash he's funny but he gets the
job done well uh it's the the gameplay
as we've seen is just so fast paced
there's so much action in it uh you know
with all the Spells the spell casting
and the magic what can you tell us about
the story and how this battle mage Jack
uh comes in Easy sort of becomes a
battle mage right yeah he kind of comes
from nothing he's uh I guess they call
him as Street rat is what he was
um but he yeah during a time of intense
trauma he summons the power to control
magic uh becomes part of the Immortals
which is like the elite Navy SEAL Squad
of this world called avium and they are
in the middle of an Ever War fighting
for the control of magic okay uh you
have a great cast you Gina Torres in it
lots of amazing actors in this
incredible really high production value
game that's coming out this summer we
don't have to wait long for it um and I
know you brought something with you to
share today which is a gameplay sequence
which one of the most epic sort of parts
of the game right yeah um so this is a
wild part of the game this trailer is
going to be showing you um The Immortals
and myself confronting Sandra directly
who is the top villain of this game
um and trying to end the ever war and
it's uh taking place in like one of the
most badass levels of a video game I've
seen we're battling on top of a 400 foot
Mech in the middle of the ocean as it
moves around
um it's wild so let's take a look all
right let's take a look at some brand
new gameplay from a mortal which comes
out this summer for PC PS5 and Xbox
thanks Darren thank you
sandrax literally pushed us to the edge
everyone that can fight already is
we're still losing
[Music]
welcome aboard immortal
what's our bearings sir North by
Northeast five knots
we'll catch him so
[Music]
remember text
down here got it
gotta get to the control
foreign
[Music]
I want to fight this war as one of you
you're what's called a try art
the pentacide has gifted you with the
ability
to manifest all three colors of matter
[Music]
we're only going to win this one
together
[Music]
love that we get to show you guys so
much amazing raw gameplay today and that
game looks incredible coming out this
summer from ascendant and EA now one
game that constantly reinvents itself is
fortnite and tomorrow chapter 4 season 3
Wilds launches and today summer game
Fest is debuting the cinematic trailer
to preview the season the center of the
island has collapsed revealing a vast
hidden jungle with ancient secrets to
discover and of course there's a whole
new battle pass lineup where you can
Unleash the Power yes of Cybertron here
we go
[Music]
all right
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
Wilds launches tomorrow
well finally guys
it's time to get to our grand finale
and it is a deep honor for me to present
this game what you're about to see is a
world premiere trailer that gives us a
new look at an expansive world we can't
wait to explore again
this game comes from a studio that
surprised the world and redefined the
RPG genre with its iconic characters and
Rich storytelling I want to thank them
for this trailer for one of Gaming's
most anticipated upcoming releases
the rumors
were true
we're still here at the scene of this
terrible disaster caused by a massive
tornado which swept through sector zero
one and two
amidst the wreckage of the expressway
search and rescue operations are already
in progress
[Music]
wow
just look at it all it's so green even
after everything we've done to it it's
still going strong it may look that way
[Music]
what's Cloud been doing these past five
years where's he been
and you're asking me this
this is gonna sound crazy but
as far as I know
Cloud was never in miebelheim five years
ago
live stream
very essence of our star
blood horsing through its planetary
veins
according to Hojo they're connected to
sephiroth
Shadows of the man I believe he called
them
sephiroth was in midgar we fought him
whatever happened
he's alive but why come back now
[Music]
after five years doing who knows what
well now I think we woke it up
angered it more like
[Music]
Feast your eyes on the Turks latest and
greatest Elena she may be new but she's
still a turd
[Music]
they say she's a monster
that she can pure inside you
into the very depths of your soul
that she can become those you hate those
you fear
those you love
green and yeah you murdered my dad
you burned my Village
[Music]
you know that I killed her
so who is she
[Music]
[Applause]
there you have it that was Final Fantasy
7 rebirth coming early 2024 to
PlayStation 5 numero Sun thank you so
much all right that's gonna do it for
summer game Fest our live showcase but
that is not the end of summer game Fest
stay tuned this weekend for updates on
many more games during sgf play days a
Hands-On event for media here in Los
Angeles including cyberpunk 2077 Phantom
Liberty as well as the Xbox and Bethesda
showcase on Sunday right now though stay
tuned for Day of the devs from I am
8-bit and double fine which celebrates
the independent game culture with a
number of new game reveals over the next
hour
we'll see you this summer later this
summer on August 22nd for Gamescom
opening night live in Germany and again
in December when we come together here
in Los Angeles to celebrate 10 years of
the game awards thanks for watching
everyone we'll see you soon
foreign
[Applause]